what is up guys fire here with another
cool tutorial this time is a small hyper
casual game and as always before we
start coding and creating and doing all
the magic we're going to take a look at
what game we're going to create but
before we do that hit that subscribe
button hit that notification button and
just smash that whitey but nothing like
those like those bloggers you know
Somesh alike anyway but seriously
subscribe hit that notification button
let's mash the like button so now let's
take a look at what game we are going to
create so when I hit the play button you
will see that when you have these
platformers they are going up our our
backgrounds going down we hear the
background music and we have different
platforms here you see you hear the
sound effects now we are dead and the
game will restart so again let's try to
beat the game and here we will also land
on one of the breakable black ones which
eventually will break and bam you see it
broke and we fell down and notice how
our cube our game player is like
rotating and stuff so yeah that is also
cool effect you will also have you see
these moving platforms that are moving
us to the side we will see how we can
create that and we will see how we can
randomize all of this and bam we are
done and the game will restart pretty
simple game I mean it looks pretty
simple but it is not very easy to create
you will see that we will add some smart
code to randomize these platforms so on
and so far we will learn a lot so yeah
stick with me and you will have a lot of
assignments in this video so if you
truly want to learn I'm giving your
assignments to complete and I'm giving
you hints how to complete that and
everything that you finish you'll show
me that in the Facebook group and then I
will grade it like you know in school
you have a plus but probably will get an
a-minus anyways well let's start and
dive into the tutorial and before we do
that you can download the asset and the
complete project from www.hp.com/recycle
ups so yeah have fun enjoy the tutorial
I am in a new project and this is
Toodee project and as always we're going
to start by importing the assets so we
have the sounds that we have the sprite
simply drag-and-drop them right here and
while I unity will import them by the
way the assets and this complete project
you can download it link will be in the
description below
so now the first thing that we're gonna
do is create our background and this is
going to be a portrayed game so we're
gonna go here and change our view now
this is really important so bookmark it
write it down on your notepad on your I
don't know piece of paper where you
write down your notes because a lot of
people have issues with this and that is
because they don't pay attention how can
you change this screen size well it's
really really simple for that let me
take my highlight tool here it is
so you see here I'm in the game tab and
right here where the game tab is you
have this where it says full HD now for
you maybe it will not say full HD will
not maybe but surely because I created
this you can click on this and while I
you see here you can have some already
predefined resolutions such as 5.4 or
4.3 or 3-2 or 16 10 16 19 and so forth
you get my point but here at the bottom
you have this plus circle so you see
this well I cannot use my highlight tool
when I'm clicking on this anyways you
see this plus circle here you can click
on it it will open this pop-up window
the label here is the name of that
resolution so name of your resolution
for example Full HD HD so on and so
forth and here you can set the width and
the height so for this example or for
this tutorial
I chose 480 by 800 s you're gonna type
with 480 height 800 and you're gonna
press ok when you do that you will see
that resolution right here here it is
and I can click on it now and bam so I
have changed the view so now I'm our
camera it's also changed you see here
how the camera is now like rectangle or
actually this is another
I think it is yeah rectangle and if I go
here if I change it to full HD you see
it is in landscape oh when I go back
here and change it to for 8800 it is in
portrait mode so this is how you change
the screen in unity and this is how
would you create a game for a portrait
resolution or for a portrait mode okay
so moving forward we are going to create
a quad so I'm gonna right click here and
go on to 3d object and create a quad now
if you followed my tutorial about the
space shooter and hopefully I've
published that before this one because I
already have them created anyways and if
you watched also my parallax scrolling
tutorial you will know what I'm gonna do
so I would encourage you to try this on
your own try creating that parallax
effect on the y-axis so that well you
can practice and then you can come back
to the video and see if you did it
correctly so I'm gonna change the quad
name to BG and I'm gonna go and right
click here in the project and create a
folder I'm going to call the material
and I'm going to go here and create a
new material I almost created a script
and this one is going to be our BG
material and attach it right here on the
BG game object so it is attached did I
attach it actually no so now it's
attached ok the next thing that we're
gonna do is change the shader from
standard here to unlit texture so while
a simple like that so now I can click on
the drop-down list we can attach a
texture here which is our sprite so we
can go here in our sprites and I can
select the background here it is so
select the BG and now drag-and-drop this
background right here and the BAM here
is our background of course we are going
to resize this BG so we need to set the
scale for the X at 6:00 and add the Y at
10 and voila this is our background so
we are in the game view and this is what
we see and if we transfer this game on
our phone this would be what we would
see I'm also going to set the Z at 10
because this is a quad and because of
this it will be rendered behind all
other game objects so set the Z and then
and of course you can change this later
on if the background is obscuring some
of the game objects so we can easily fix
that anyways go here in the assets and
right click and create a new folder for
scripts and inside of that one I'm gonna
right click and create a new folder for
our BG scripts and inside right-click
and create a c-sharp one this is going
to be BG scroll and we're going to
attach it on the BG game object so I'm
gonna go here and attach it so simply
drag it and drop it and double click
here open it in Visual Studio now if you
watch a couple of my previous tutorials
you will probably notice that I'm
testing you along the way and it's not
gonna be different in this one so
prepare for a test pretty soon anyways
we are going to have here a public float
for our scroll underscore speed which by
default I'm going to see 0.3 now of
course you can change this you see I set
it to be public so if the speed is not
what we want we can change it easily we
are also going to get a reference to the
private mesh a render that I'm gonna
call mesh renderer and I would encourage
you to try to do this on your own as I
already said try to scroll it on your
own and if you watch my space shooter
tutorial you will see one problem that
you're gonna get same as what we did in
our spaceship shooter tutorial so here
we're going to say mesh a render is
equal to get component and that's gonna
be our mesh renderer component so simply
now here below the update we are going
to create void scroll and inside of this
function first of all we're going to
call it in the update so we are going to
say here scroll let's curl speed but
scroll this one right here so scroll and
we are going to inside of this function
we're going to program our functionality
for scrolling and what we're simply
going to
is we're going to say here vector to
offset we're going to get the offset of
the texture which is going to be equal
to mesh renderer dot get texture or
actually shared material excuse me that
get texture offset and we need to pass
the name of the texture and the texture
name in quotes is underscore main text
this is the name of the texture so
underscore main text would capital m
capital T now you know that I don't like
this hard coding so your first
assignment for this video is to create a
common script or a shared script that
has all the names tags and so on and so
forth that we are going to use that we
write as strings so I want you to do
that because I'm not going to do it here
that's your job I'm testing you out
anyways here we're going to say I've set
that Y so the Y axes we're going to see
plus equals time dot Delta time
multiplied with the scroll speed and
voila
after that we simply need to call our
mesh render that share material dot set
texture offset so set texture offset and
again we need to pass the name which is
the same right here and this is why I
don't like hard coding and here we are
going to set the offset now this is one
reason why I don't love hard coding you
see here we're using this and here we
are using this it is better to declare
that variable first in a common script
if you're going to use it on multiple
places in case of this script you can
declare it right here so you can simply
declare it here as a private string but
I'm not gonna do that that's your job so
you need to fix that anyways if I go in
side of unity and if I clear for is the
console for some reason I like clearing
the console I don't know why don't judge
me and if I hit the play button the
script is attached and we should see
that our background will start to scroll
and voila
in deed our background started to scroll
but where is our background we don't
see it anymore well let me go here and
set the offset Y back to one so what is
wrong here what did we do and let me set
the offset here actually offset here
zero zero so yeah what did we do and why
isn't it
scrolling it is scrolling but it's not
scrolling how we intended it to scroll
and as I said this is the same issue we
had in the space shooter tutorial in the
2d space shooter the same exact issue if
you follow that you would know what we
need to do is go back here inside of our
sprites and select the background and I
like this approach really because it is
beneficial for you I first show you the
problem that you will have and how you
can fix it so you're going to select the
background and here in the options you
see here with the options that we have
we have this advanced right here if it's
folded you're going to unfold it so if
it's folded like this actually it's
below excuse me if we set the texture
like this to default then it would be in
the advanced but here is actually below
where it says this wrap mode you see
this let me just go here and clear it
you see this wrap mode right here this
is a drop-down list currently it is set
to clamp we need to click here and we
need to set to repeat and then we need
to hit apply at the bottom right corner
here for this texture or for this sprite
for this to take effect for this change
to take effect so hit apply on repeat
and now if I go here and hit the play
button we will see that the BG will
scroll and scroll and scroll and it will
repeat so the texture will repeat itself
and this is what we need to do so when
these textures are not working they are
not scrolling how they supposed to be in
your code and you did this right here
then the issue is simply going here
selecting the background and sending the
wrap mode to repeat and voila that will
fix the issue moving forward the next
thing that we are going to do is prepare
our platforms because we're going to
have different platforms so first of all
I'm going to go into the sprites and
plot
folder and then into the standard
platform so this one standard platform
you're going to put it here and voila
this is our platform so what I'm gonna
do is simply name it platform and if you
remember a few moments ago when I said
it Herbie just said the z axis of our BG
because it's a quad at 10:00 well pay
attention what happened is if I if I set
it and for example negative 11 or if I
set it a negative 7 you see it obscures
our platform that's why I'm going to set
it simply at 10:00 and voila here it is
our platform is in front of it now the
next thing that I'm gonna do is set that
order in layer for the platform at 1 so
you see this right here I'll basically
here where it's circled it says order in
layer and I set it here to 1 that's the
order that we're going to use to draw
the platform's or the game object or the
element that has a sprite left render
and it's on order in layer 0 it will be
rendered behind if you don't know 100%
what I'm talking about go and watch my
video about orders or rendering layers
and so on and so forth now of course
this is too large for a platform for so
what I'm gonna do is set point 5 point 5
for X and y scale that is so scale X and
scale Y point 5 point 5 I'm also going
to take here box Collider 2d and attach
that box Collider 2d on our platform I
am also going to click here add
component and add a rigidbody component
and this is going to be a rigidbody 2d
so please pay attention I say always I
say this all the time it's a rigidbody
2d when we cover a 2-d game so you have
here two choices a rigid body and
rigidbody 2d I think unity should put
here rigidbody 3d so that we know well I
know and you know now but somebody can
get confused about using the rigidbody
what I'm also going to do is because if
we run the game now if I press the play
button pay attention see the platform
simply felt that we don't want that what
we need to do is set the body type from
dynamic to
kinematics oh let me go here clear the
pencil you see here the body type for
the rigid body this one right here we
are going to set that so click on the
drop-down list to kinematic what is
kinematic kinematic is not affected by
gravity we can affect it by velocity or
add force and so on and so forth
but gravity will not affect this rigid
body whereas dynamic is affected by
gravity so this is for our platform now
we also have a breakable platform so I'm
going to take another standard platform
or actually I'm just gonna duplicate
this one and I'm going to rename this
one to breakable plat form so plat form
like this and let me just lower it below
a little bit so here it is we are going
to have everything here so same
components box Collider so on and so
forth but I'm also going to click here
on a head component and add an animator
so animator and hit enter and I'm going
to put this animator here no particular
reason why I'm reordering the component
so it's not like your game is going to
run better or you're going to be a
better game developer if you do this my
personal preference so now that we have
this animator what I'm gonna do is go
here and right click and create a folder
for animations and this is in the assets
folder so create the animations folder
and inside I'm going to create another
one so this one is going to be breakable
breakable plant form animations
animations like this inside I'm simply
gonna right-click and create an animator
controller and this one's going to be
breakable controller and select the
breakable platform and attach the
controller so simply drag and drop it
right here I'm also going to set the
animation tab here and selecting the
breakable platform click here create and
it's gonna prompt us to create an
animation the first one is going to be
the idle animation so simply name it
idle and then I'll simply name it like
that name it idle so what is the next
thing to do the next thing is to
click here where it says idle and if you
don't see where that is that is here in
the animation tab you see and here you
will have the idle you see the animation
of we are created this is a clickable
button so you can click on that and it
will open this drop-down list showing
all the animations that we have and
currently we only have idle so I'm going
to click here create a new clip and this
one is going to be break animations I'm
simply going to name it break and hit
enter to save now in the break animation
I'm gonna go quickly in sprites
platforms and standard platform in the
break animation select these crack 0 1 2
& 3 and if I preview it you see what
happens you see simply if I pay
attention in the bottom right corner by
the way so you will see it has it's
simulating cracks it's not cracked like
the way you think it is it's crack when
somebody when something cracks ok not
the way naughty naughty boys with their
naughty whatever F anyways so you see
here platform crack 0 1 2 & 3 simply
drag and drop it here and this is for
the breakable but for the idle we're
simply going to put the standard
platform and while we're good to go now
before we proceed and do anything we can
preview this so I can go here and select
the break and I can zoom in here and pay
attention see it is breaking you see
this is the animation you see it's fast
when I simply hit the play button we
will change the speed of this animation
inside so if I go now so let me go here
actually no we cannot do that because
let me select the breakable platform
yeah the idle one he is the default one
so let's set the default one the break
one and if I go here we'll see you see
how it is breaking so what I'm gonna do
is let's set the speed of the break to
point to maybe point one yeah point one
can do even point 0 5 yeah point 0 5 or
point I don't know 0 8 that's enough I
think what we also need to do is double
click on the break animation here the
orange one now so double click on it
uncheck the loop time so click here and
uncheck the
time now let me click on this again so
the play button yeah this is totally
fine this is totally fine what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to right-click on the
Idol and set it back as a layer default
set which means the Idol will be the
animation the default one that's going
to be played now this is for our
platforms that breakable and the
platform regular now we also have a
spike platform so I'm going to simply
drag and drop it here here it is and by
the way let me just lower it here and
I'm going to set the order in layer two
one and this is what I was talking about
did you see if I said the order in
linear zero pay attention how the spike
platform will be rendered behind you see
it's rendered behind this one if I set
the order in layer two one now they are
on the same order layer which means
sometimes one element can be rendered
first and sometimes another element can
be rendered first but if I set it at two
you see now the blue platform is behind
the spike platform so this is that order
and I have a separate tutorial for that
anyways moving forward our spike
platform set the scale 0.5 point five
for X&Y
attach a box Collider and this box
Collider is going to be a trigger and
actually excuse me here it's a box
Collider 2d and let me check here if I
attach a box Collider 2d on these boat -
yeah so it's a box Collider 2d and check
it to be a trigger and let me just go
here in the game to see well we can
resize it ellaby we don't want it to be
like this you see because now this is
circling or actually I don't know how
you can say that this is a rectangle so
it's correct angling this spike platform
anyways we want to resize a little bit
so on the X simply resize a little bit
like this on the wide just a little bit
maybe like this yeah we are good to go
now pay attention here we have the size
X 2.4 and size Y 0.61 this is for the
size of the box Collider
again we are going to attach a component
which is going to be a rigidbody 2d and
we are going to change the body type to
kinematic from die
Namek so voila we are good to go now
this is for these platforms we also have
the speed platform so simply what you're
gonna do is first of all go into
animations and right click here folder
and this is going to be our moving
platform and what we're simply going to
do is go here inside so sprites and
platforms and speed platform this is the
folder so go here and we have eight of
these so select eight so select all of
them select all of these eight and drag
and drop them right here in the scene
when you do that it will prompt this
window for us to create an animation
what I'm gonna do is go in the
animations folder moving platforms and
simply here I'm going to say move and
this is going to be that animation and
voila and I'm going to name this one how
am I going to name its speed platform or
moving platform yeah speed platform and
it's going to be speed platform left and
because we're also going to have a right
one we will see in a moment how we're
going to create that set the order in
layer to one and if I run the game now
we will see that animation so pay
attention you see now voila this is the
animation of the speed platform which
will move our player to the left side
now again we are going to also I have a
platform that's good you move him to the
right side but first of all let me set
the scale to point five point five
because we want it to be smaller let me
attach a box Collider 2d and make an a
trigger actually no excuse me this one
will not be a trigger only the spike
platform others are not triggers they're
going to be solid game objects so here
add component a rigidbody 2d make it
kinematic and we are good to go
so yeah this is for the platform now
this is for the left one what I'm gonna
do is duplicate it command D or shift or
actually control the on Windows and you
can also go here under edit and
duplicate that also works so what I'm
gonna do is take the speed platform and
change this from left to right
I'm going to move it up a little bit so
here and simply here in the sprite
component we have this flip you see we
have the flip and what we can do is
simply check the X for the flip and pay
attention what's gonna happen to this
one when I check the X BAM you see now
it is pointing to the right side and if
I run the game we will see that one is
playing the animation left you see and
another one is playing the animation to
the right side
voila now that we have prepared all of
our platforms I can go here in assets
and right click and create a new folder
and prefabs well name the folder prefabs
and go here right click and create
another folder this is going to be our
platform prefabs and before we proceed
to do anything I'm going to create a
platform script so that we can attach it
so we can attach the platform script and
then we can save them as prefab so let's
go here in the scripts and right click
and folder and platform scripts like
this and right click here and C sharp
script and this is going to be the
platform script select all of them so
all of them platform breakable platform
so on and so forth and go at the bottom
on add component and click there and
search for platform script this way you
will attach the script on every single
one of these game objects so you see
every single one of them has now a
platform script and if you scroll you
will see that all have a platform script
so now let me just open the platform
script here and add some variables that
we will need for every platform so that
we can check them and then we will be
able to well continue with our game so
what do we need well first of all we
need a public float move underscore
speed by default let's say it's equal to
2 we are also going to see here public
float bound Y which is going to be equal
to 6 now what is this well because our
platforms are going to move from down to
bottom
eventually they will get out of screen
so if you see here if I take any
platform if I take this one and I start
moving it you see it's gonna move and
eventually it's gonna go out of screen
well when it gets to the point of six
you see here so this is the six and I've
measured this in the game while I was
preparing it so I simply move the
platform and I said okay here the
platform is out of screen it will not be
visible visible it will not be visible
when I deactivate it because what do I
mean by this well I don't want the
platform to get up to here it's still in
our game and then I simply turn it off
like this BAM
no we want the platform to let me go
here we're on the platform to move above
here so it's out of sight and then we
are going to deactivate it but for that
we need to know where that bound is
going to be and that bound is number six
as you just saw me demonstrate that now
here we are also going to have a public
Bull moving platform underscore left and
you can assume that we are also going to
have a moving platform right so all
right and we're also going to have is
breakable and we're also going to have
is spike and we're also going to have is
platform this is how we are going to
determine which platform is using this
script and now we are going to check
these check boxes but before they let me
simply also add here a private animator
Adam and then we can continue with
everything so now before we save them as
prefab select every platform and the
node which platform it is so if I go
here this platform is a regular platform
so we're going to check the check box is
platform breakable platform is a
breakable one so we're going to check is
breakable for the check box the spike
platform selected and we're going to
check is spiked for the speed platform
left we're going to check moving
platform left and actually we can
reining that to speed but that's up to
you anyways you get my point this is the
left one and speed platform right check
the check box for that one
as well and voila now we have prepared
our platforms and we can safely go now
into the prefabs folder and drag and
drop them one by one so this one and all
of them make sure that you don't delete
one of these that you didn't save as a
prefab prior to this because if you do
you will lose it then we will need to go
again
and add a component a box Collider a
rigidbody a script the nanometer
depending on which platform you deleted
and now I can delete them because I have
them as prefabs and we're only left with
our regular platform and we can continue
with the script so let's get back here
in Visual Studio the first thing is
we're gonna do here in awake function
secrete awake function I'm going to test
if is breakable which means if the
platform holding this script is the
breakable platform we are going to say
atom is equal to get component animator
we will deal with this later but I'm
just going to put it here so that we
don't for get it so what is the next
thing to do well I can simply remove the
start function we can leave only the
update and we can create below function
so void move not on animation move only
move and in the update here I'm going to
say move and what we're gonna do here
simply is we are going to move the
platform you're going to say vector to
is temp well the name of that variable
is equal to transform that position
which is the current position of the
platform then we're simply going to say
temp dot y plus equals to the move speed
multiply that with time that Delta time
voila
and below we're simply going to say
transform position is equal to temporary
position and since this is moving inside
of the update we can go here we can test
it out and I'm going to show you what
that bound means for us because if I go
here in the in that scene we you see now
the platform is out of the view but it's
still there
and here we don't see it in the game
see it's there it's up it's going so we
need to add an extra line of code here
we need to test if our temp so if our
temp that Y is greater than or equal to
the bound Y it's a bound Y like this
then we're simply going to say
gameobject.setactive is equal to false
Walla and we are good to go so now it
will deactivate it self and we can test
that out now so I can go here in unity
and let me just take a look at the scene
view so you will see now when it gets
somewhere around here
pay attention let me just switch to the
scene here right away pay attention now
BAM it is deactivated so this is what we
need so far this is what we need for our
platform to make them move now later on
we add our player we will detect what
we're gonna do with him but for now I'm
gonna right click here in the hierarchy
and I'm going to go and create an empty
game object and I'm going to set x y&z
to 0 0 0 and this one is going to be our
platform spawner I'm also going to go
back in the scripts folder and platform
scripts and right click here and create
a c-sharp script and this one's going to
be platform script now actually excuse
me
no it's platform spawner so I deleted
this one right click again and go here
and this was going to be platforms honor
so platform spawner now what are we
going to do with this platform spawner
well he is going to be responsible for
spawning our platforms and we are simply
going to reposition him somewhere around
here let me just tag him
so this is our platform spawner let's
say at negative 8 this is where his
initial position is going to be and from
within there we are going to spawn the
platform's so let's attach this platform
spawner script on him and of course we
need variables to make this happen so
let me just do my thing here and class
give a little
of space you know the drill don't even
judge me don't even think about judging
me so what we need well first of all
here we're going to see public game
object is going to be our plot for
prefab this is the regular platform we
are also going to have a public spike
platform prefab we are also going to
have a public game object array and this
is going to be moving platforms like
this in public game object breakable
platform so breakable plat form now I
can also MIT here the underscore we have
the platform spike moving platforms and
breakable platform as you can assume
what we are going to do with these is
that we are going to spawn them now for
that we need to have a spawn timer so
we're going to see here public float
platform spawn timer so spawn timer is
gonna be equal to two apps every two
seconds and we're also going to have
here our private float so float current
current platform spawn timer this one we
are now going to declare and we're also
going to have a private int plat form
spawn count count and we also need to
have a public float minimum underscore X
which is going to be equal to an maximum
underscore X which is going to be equal
to now what I did what are they going to
be equal to well if I take now the
platform this one right here and if I
move it till to the bounds where it's
well near the end but it's not outside
so it's something like this here I think
- so this is negative two this is where
the minimum is going to be so negative
two and maximum is going to be positive
voila simple like that so if I go back
here
the minimum is going to be negative to F
and the maximum is going to be 2 so
we're going to spawn them between these
two downs now inside of the start the
first thing that we are going to do is
we are going to set the current platform
spawner timer or current platform spawn
timer to be equal to platform so
platform spawn timer why are we going to
do it like this we will see in a second
for that we need to create here a
function so void spawn platform splat
forms like this and in the update we are
going to call this function so spawn
platforms which is going to start
spawning all the platforms now what we
are going to do is the following we are
going to see current platform spawn
timer plus equals time Delta time we did
this in numerius of my previous
tutorials we did this in the
first-person shooter we did this in the
beat em up game we did this in the 2d
space shooter we are simply going to use
this variable to denote when the value
is larger so here we are going to test
if our current so current platform spawn
timer is greater or equal to the
platform spawn timer so the current time
if it's greater than this time and this
time here we set it at 2 but it's a
public variable we can also change it so
if we think that we need to put a lower
value I don't know something like let's
say 1.8 for example so I can copy this
and I can go here and select the
platform spawner and you can put here
1.8 so that works as well and while we
are here let me quickly go here in the
prefabs and attach the prefab so here
platform prefab is the platform one the
regular one spike here it is spike 1
this is for the moving so the size is
going to be 2 we have the left here it
is left we have the right here it is
right and the breakable platform so here
it is breakable platform make sure that
you add all of these or
will not work if you don't do that now
going back here we set the timer to 1.8
now and here we're setting the current
platform spawn timer to be equal to that
value which means as soon as we hit this
in the update we are adding to this
value time dot Delta time which is a
very small number but over time because
it's called in the update which is
called every frame which means 60 times
in a second we are going to add this
value and it will over time get to the
point where it will have a greater value
than this one when that happens our
going to spawn a platform so here spawn
platform
okay so what's gonna happen here first
of all we are going to say our platform
count or spawn count plus plus so we are
going to increase it and we are going to
do the following we are going to see
here vector3 temporary position is equal
to transform that position and we're
going to see temp dot X is gonna be
equal to a random arranged between
minimum X and the maximum X voila
so that is going to be the temporary or
actually excuse me this is the X not the
Y so X will be between minimum X and the
maximum X ok now below we are going to
say game object and we are going to say
new platform which by default is equal
to null but now remove this animator
what am i doing here but now we are
going to test here so we are going to
type here if our platform spawn count
this one right here that we are
incrementing if that value and let me
just do it again platform spawn count if
the value is lower than 2 we are going
to do what we are going to say new
platform so new platform is equal to
instantiate and we are going to
instantiate the platform prefab and
we're going to use the temp as the
position and we are going to use
quaternion that identity for the
rotation this is if the value is less or
actually if it's less than 2 so that
will be when the value is 1 and 2
because 2 is
less than two else if our platform so
else if flat for spawn count is equal to
two so if it's equal to two we are going
to randomize we are going to either
spawn a spike or actually a moving
platform so let me just do my thing here
we're going to say if random dot why
rent if random that range between zero
and two if it's greater than zero so if
it is greater than zero we are again
going to do this right here so we're
simply going to spawn a new platform
which is the regular platform else if
that is not the key is if random range
here between 0 and 2 is not greater than
0 we're going to say new platform is
equal to instantiate and here I'm going
to use the moving platform so moving
platforms and the element that's at the
random range between 0 and moving
platforms that lengths like this and we
need to see comma and we need to say
temp and we need to say quaternion
identity so you see here what we are
doing we are randomizing things based on
the platform spawn counts so we are
incrementing it so we are incrementing
its value and when that value is less
than 2 we're going to spawn a regular
platform so platform prefab what that
value is equal to 2 we are going to
randomize either we will spawn the
regular platform or we will spawn a new
platform which actually in your platform
we will spawn a moving platform and
we're using a random range between 0 and
moving platforms length to randomize
that and again random range between 0
and 2 will return 0 and 1 it will not
return 2 because if I hover over you
will see that it will return an integer
and when we use integers with a random
range it will not include the last
number so the last number is exclusive
which means it can either return 0 or 1
but if we use F so if we adhere F and F
that means it will I'd return 0 1 or 2
or any number in between so moving
forward here we are going to test else
if our current platform or platform
spawn count is equal to number 3 now if
it's equal to number 3 again we are
going to randomized things so we're
going to do exactly the same thing here
but instead of spawning the moving
platform so if the random range is
greater than 0 we will spawn the
platform prefab the length the regular
platform prefab if it is not then we are
going to instantiate here and what I'm
going to do is simply remove this we are
going to instantiate the spike so if
it's not then instantiate the spike
platform prefab again this is randomized
and again I'm going to copy these lines
of code here so copy and simply paste
them here again else if platform spawn
count is equal to number 4 and here
instead of spawning the spike we're
going to spawn the breakable platform
wallah and at the end here for our
platform spawn count number 4 this is
really really really important to do we
need to call this platform spawn count
is equal to 0 to reset it so that we can
again go back through all this iteration
if we don't do this right here if we
don't reset it then we will have issues
we will never go again through this
iteration and probably will not I did
not test it out but I believe that we
will not have spawn platforms anymore
and at the end outside of all of these
if-else statements at the bottom we need
to say new platform that transform that
parent is equal to transform now I will
demonstrate in a moment why we are going
to do this but for now I'm going to
comment this out and at the bottom as
well we are going to say current
platform spawn timer is equal to 0 reset
the timer you see here reset this timer
because we are only going to allow it to
spawn once then go again from 0 and
spawn again and go again from 0 so on
and so forth
so let's go and take a look at what we
have here so if i close
the clear the console that is if I hit
the play button we will see now that the
platform spawner was thought spawning so
you see we have the platform now we have
the speed platform you see now we have
the platform breakable platform platform
again so again platform clone we will
have a spike eventually break a ball son
and so forth now also you see that all
of these are simply being spawned in the
hierarchy and you see how the hierarchy
can get messed up well for that we can
do this we can simply go here and we can
set the parent of the new platform
transform parent is equal to the
transform which is the transform of the
platform spawner
so pay attention now every new platform
that's gonna be spawned will be a child
of the platform spawner
so now our hierarchy will not get
clustered it will not get you see now
they're all under the platform spawner
they're being spawned that you see now
we have the spike we have a regular
platform we have again a regular one now
we have the moving one we have again the
regular actually probably some of these
are breakable I don't see so this one is
the speed right so on and so forth so
you see how we are randomizing and all
these platforms are getting a chance to
be spawned so we have the moving
platforms we have the spiked ones we
have the breakable ones we have the
regular ones of course the regular ones
are being spawned the most because if we
spawn all others then the player will
have no chance if we go back here again
and analyze the code what we're simply
doing we're using this to control the
spawning this right here is clear if not
put a comment below this video and I
will answer simple as that anyway
anyways I'm using the platform spawn
counter to control the spawning queue
C++ which means incrementing it when
that value for as long as that value is
less than two we are going to spawn a
regular platform when that value gets to
be equal to two we are going to either
spawn a regular platform or a moving
platform when that value gets to three
we will either spawn a regular platform
or a spiked platform you get the point
so based on this increment and
last increment here we need to set it
equal to zero if we don't do that let's
check it out
I did not test it out but I believe it
will stop spawning the platform's so
let's see if that is the case so yeah we
have one platform we have another
platform three four platforms and let's
see if we're going to yeah no you see
here Bam Bam Bam Bam zero you see
actually we get a null reference
exception so yeah we get a null
reference exception right here because
we are using new platform parent and as
you can see here we set it to be equal
to null and we're not spawning any more
platforms one way to fix this of course
is to uncomment this but when you have a
null you see here when you have a null
game object what you can do is you can
do this you can say if new platform is
not equal to null or simply if new
platform and simply face this here so if
new platform meaning if it's not equal
to null if we have a reference and if
you don't know what a reference is if
you don't know classes and objects you
don't understand that concept I have a
video for that I will put it in the link
put it in the link put the link in the
description below if you don't find the
link please remind me it can happen that
I forget to put it anyways you see when
we don't reset the platform spawn count
we did not get a chance to spawn your
platforms and we got an old reference
exception here because of that so we
need to reset it back here to 0 for this
iteration again to work and go through
all of these platforms no we tested it
how am I gonna test it out again you can
do that on your own test it and if you
have any issues post a comment below or
better yet post a comment on my facebook
group and I or somebody else there will
respond ok now we can add the player in
our game so for that I'm gonna go into
the project and sprites and voila
here is our player here is the crazy
dude here is the crazy cube here is the
crazy well here is the player anymore
hey I'm going to save point 5 point 5
for X action
I think we need to resize a player a
little bit more so let's go here at
point three point three yeah point three
will do now for the initial platform so
the first one that is here I'm going to
set that in negative four so let's take
it here negative four negative four not
four and here is going to be the initial
platform now let me take the player
here's at the middle we are going to
attach a box Collider 2d so not to make
it a trigger do not make the player a
trigger we are also going to attach a
rigidbody 2d now we are going to leave
it dynamic for the player now for the
mass I'm going to set here zero but it
cannot be 0 it will be zero zero point
zero point blah blah blah one anyways
for the gravity scale I'm going to set
that at three and voila I'm not going to
set the constraints because that is
going to allow us to roll the player as
you saw in that preview video and now we
can first create the player movement so
we can go into assets and scripts and
right click here go on there folder and
player script and inside of this one I'm
going to right click and create a new
c-sharp script and this was going to be
player movement ok so the player
movement and attach it on the player so
let's build here attach it on the player
can add script now don't worry about
this this is I don't know why because it
probably did not get a chance to create
I was so quick to attach the script that
unity did not manage to create it before
I try to attach it anyways let me go
here into the prefabs and quickly drag
and drop the player in the prefabs and
I'm going to open the script in Visual
Studio and let's go here so what is the
next thing to do so here I'm going to
see class and hold enter to give a
little bit of space so what do we need
to move the player well simply we need
private rigidbody so private rigidbody
2d which I'm going to call my body we
are going to use the rigidbody to move
the player opposed to the platform's
which we are using their transform to
move them so this is another way to do
it and we need a public float move speed
by default I'm going to say it's equal
to one of course we set it to be public
which means that we can change it I
don't know if you want to change it to
two you can change it in the inspector
so don't worry about that
so in the awake first of all change
start to awake and inside of this one we
are going to say my body is equal to get
component rigidbody2d now when you have
components like these rigid body or I
don't know how your source or whatever
make sure that every single time you use
get component so don't forget to do that
because you will get an old reference
exception and if you have components in
your script and you get an old reference
exception if the error is pointing to
some of the components so for example if
I try to use rigid body like this so if
I see here void move not on animation
over on animator move simply move and if
I try to do something like my body the
glossy T dot blah blah blah and the
error points here to this line that
means you did not use get component to
get a reference to the component okay
what we're gonna do in our move and by
the way we're going to call the move in
the fixed update not update but fixed
update so change the update in T fixed
update and I know I said fixed update
four times already
anyways fixed update is used to move
game objects with the rigidbody if we
were to use the transform like we're
using here for our platforms then we
would use the update which is a better
or more suitable for that purpose but
using the rigidbody use the fixed update
so what you're going to do here we're
going to test if our input get axis or
raw so get axis raw and here we're going
to say horizontal and if that value is
greater than zero we are going to do
what we are going to say my body
velocity is equal to new vector2
and here i'm going to say move speed for
the x and my body velocity dot y for the
y velocity
below I'm simply going to copy this line
and here I'm going to test if it's lower
than zero and here I'm going to say
negative move speed again your
assignment is to have a separate script
which holds these variables like this
horizontal you can call it from that I
already did this in couple of my
tutorials so now it's up to you to test
your knowledge and see if you actually
learn something even if you're paying
attention to your teacher here okay pay
attention okay anyways more important it
won't be me enough being me enough about
me being silly so the horizontal get X
is raw if we press the right arrow key
or the B key this value will be greater
than zero which means it will be equal
to one if we press the left arrow key
and we press the a key this value will
be negative one which means lower than
zero now I did this in numerous examples
what you're gonna do is use the print
statement like this and you're going to
print input.getaxis and horizontal and
then start pressing these keys that I
already said and then you will you will
see the difference so here I'm going to
say move before we proceed to test this
out I'm also going to create here a
public void platform move would the
float X and here what I'm going to
simply do is take all of this and I'm
going to say my body Milazzo T is equal
to and here I'm going to pass X because
we are going to use this one in our
moving platforms so in our moving
platforms we are going to use this one
in order to in order to move the player
so let's test it out to see if this
actually works so let's go here and
first of all clear the console I'm going
to hit the play button so now the player
will fall on the platform's you can see
and yeah we can also go like this you
see now when we fall on these so when we
fall on that one it will suppose to be
if it would move us and bam we we died
anyways this works now one thing that it
does not work if I go here the bounds
don't work so if I go outside of the
bounds up it does not work so I'm up and
I can go like this down
and below well we need to detect that
but also the bounds on the left and the
right side don't work so let me try to
do that let's hopefully one of these
platforms will be closer to the left or
right side so pay attention now I can go
outside you see ma'am I went outside of
the left side so for that we're gonna go
here and in the scripts player scripts
that is right click and create a new C
sharp script and this one is going to be
player bounce and we are going to attach
it on the player so select the player
game object drag and drop the player
bounce and go here overrides and apply
all let me double click this and open it
in visual studio and let's go here
quickly
voila and below here let me just tag the
class and give a little bit of space so
what do we need for our bounce we need
the bounce on the X and the y are
actually on the X left and right so
we're going to say public float minimum
underscore X is gonna be equal to
negative 2.6 F don't ask me how I've got
this you already saw I just measured
it's same as what I did with our
platform so I took the player moved it
to the left side saw the bounce and I
simply took that value and voila for the
maximum X it's gonna be equal to two
point six F and for the minimum Y E is
gonna be equal to negative five point
six F what is the minimum Y or the
minimum y will determine how far can the
player falls down here you see here
below our camera below the platforms and
when that value is hit then the player
will simply die and we are going to
remove this because we don't need it I
am going to remove this comment as well
and in the update we are going to call
check bounce function that we still did
not create so below we are going to say
void check bounce and inside of this one
we are simply going to say vector to
temporary position is equal to transform
that position and here we're going to
test if our temp that
X is greater than the maximum X value
then our temp X is going to be equal to
the maximum value we're not going to
allow it to go above you see what I'm
doing here it means if our current value
of the transform position X is greater
than the maximum value then we're not
going to allow it to go above that value
so we're going to set it to be equal to
that value so it will not allow it
basically it is something like this
let's see this is the maximum axial max
X is this point right here if we try to
go outside and we are here where I'm
pointing with the X we will detect that
by using this which means we will reset
to here where this point is we will
reset at this point not going outside of
these bounds this is what I'm doing here
and simply here I'm going to test if so
if our temp X is lower than the minimum
X then our temp X is equal to minimum X
same principle is except for the minimum
value same principle if we try to go
below that value we will not allow it we
will reset it back and here we're going
to say if our temp that Y is less than
or equal to the minimum Y that means we
fell down so we fell down and we are
going to do what we are simply going to
test if we are out of bounce and for
that here above we are going to create a
private pool which is going to be out of
out of underscore downs so for that we
need to test it so here I'm going to say
if with an exclamation mark if we are
not outside of bounds what is an
exclamation mark doing here an
exclamation mark used with the boolean
will make the boolean the opposite which
means if this out of bounce has a value
of false
this will make it true if it has a value
of true this will make it false so it
will make it the opposite so essentially
here or asking if we are not out of
bounds when we reach this point then we
are going to go out of bounds so we are
going to say out of bounce is now true
we are out of bounds
and we are going to call our sound
manager so sound manager that instance
that that sound we will create this
later and also here we're going to call
our game manager that instance that
hurry
start game and voila we are good to go
basically this is for our players no and
so we can go back here and let me hit
the play button and now if I try to go
out of bounds for example if I try to go
here it well I could not see that
because the movement was slow and I
could not get till the end or to the
right side so let's try to do it here
okay on the left side you see now I
cannot go and actually what did we do
let me go here where's my player where
did the player go did we attach the
script on the player so minimum X
maximum X let me go here oh yeah yeah of
course
of course why why shouldn't I be stupid
like that one thing that I did forget to
do here is that we need to do this we
need to say transform that position is
equal to temp to reset these values back
to our current position that's why our
player went out of bounds anyways so
let's test that out right now so let's
go here and hit the play button
so let's hopefully wait for one of these
partners to be closer to one of the
edges okay let's try to go out of Bounce
you see now I cannot go out about your
song well you saw I don't need to repeat
that okay the next thing to do is
finally detect what will happen when we
start landing on the platform so we need
to do that now we are going to do that
for the player and we are going to do
that as well for our platforms so in
order to do that first of all I'm going
to create the top spikes let me just
select the BG here it is and I'm going
to do something like this I'm going to
go and create an empty game object is
going to be our top spikes
here here here 0 0 0 I'm also going to
go under tags and add the tag so 1 is
going to be a top spike tag so I believe
this is the only one that we need we
will see in a moment so simply add the
top spike and select the top spikes and
tag them with the top spike tag so now
let's go here in our sprites and here is
our spike here it is I'm going to put it
here in our scene
voila this is our spike let me set the
order in layer two and set the spike as
a child of the top spike and we need to
move it here up so this is where we want
to put it right here now I'm also going
to duplicate it and move this one so let
me move it like this and this one's
going to be here why don't I see the
arrows correctly apparently i zoom in
depth
let me just reset the layout so that I
can actually see this and go back here
so now I believe I can zoom however how
much I want to zoom and I can see yeah
that was unity lagging don't worry about
that so let's duplicate it again and
move it here hold the V key not the WB
key and hold it you see now how this
moves with the mouse and this I mean you
see the arrows and that rectangle so
selected to hold the B key come on what
am I doing here
so it's spiked - not important why is
this not working ok ok now it's working
so V key and you see how the arrows are
moving
depending on where my mouse is so I'm
going to go here and snap and you see
holding the B key will snap it right
next to each other so again I'm going to
duplicate it and the V key and snap it
so come on why are you playing with me
so V key snap it duplicated move it over
here B key snap it and you get the drill
this is what we need to do so simply
move it and snap
again let me select it correctly move it
here and snap it again move it and snap
it and one more move it and snap it now
duplicate the duplicates so don't
duplicate the original not only the
duplicates and move them here and
holding the V key I'm going to snap them
and while I see voila here are our top
spikes of course it would not be smart
or vah or wise or higher on a college to
put a Collider on every single one these
spikes instead what I'm gonna do is take
the stop spikes game object and go here
and add the box Collider 2d this one is
going to be a trigger and I'm going to
resize it first of all on the y-axis
something like this and on the x-axis
something like this and voila so now
when we collide with the player the
player will be killed and let's let's
let's program that so let's go here
first of all in the platform script so
for the platforms what do we need right
here below our move we need a couple of
more variable arts with a couple of more
functions the first one is going to be
void break above the deactivate so
deactivate the breakable game object and
simply here we're going to say invoke
and we're going to invoke a function and
that functions name is going to be void
breakable or deactivate game object like
this this is the name of the function
and here we're simply going to say
gameobject.setactive false and here
we're going to call our sound manager
the instance dot ice break sound we will
do this later don't worry but simply
take the name of this function and put
it here and we're going to invoke this
after 0.3 seconds after 0.3 seconds we
are going to invoke this okay this is
for the breakable we will see we will
add this by the way since we are already
here let's quickly go in our breakable
so go into the project and let me
go into the prefabs and platform prefabs
take the breakable open it and go in the
animation and select the break animation
and then go out the last frame add an
animation event and go here and select
breakable deactivate this is the one
that we need to call and voila
it will then deactivate the breakable
after point three of a second so simply
go here click this button to add an
animation and we did this the marys of
time so expect you to know this so what
is the next thing to do the next thing
is to create void on trigger enter 2d so
in the on trigger enter 2d and I'm going
to change the collision name to target
we are going to test if our target tag
is equal to player so if we have
collided with the player and immediately
when you do something like this go here
and make sure that the player is tagged
with the player tag so select the player
here it is player go here on their tags
and tag him with the player tag just so
that we make sure and go here and
override and apply all we need to make
sure that this is the case or otherwise
we will have problems so in our
ontriggerenter what we're gonna do if we
are colliding with the player and if is
spiked so if the game object that is
holding the script is the spike game
object we are simply going to do what we
are going to say target that game object
or actually target transform position is
equal to new vector2 and I'm going to
reset the players position at 1000 1000
so that I can remove it from the view
then we are going to call our sound
manager so sound manager instance that
game over sound and we're going to call
our game manager that instance dot
restart game of course we still did not
create these but this is what we are
going to do what is the next thing
that's going to happen right below we
are also going to have on collision
enter so on
version enter 2d what is the what is the
reason what is the difference between
ontriggerenter 2d and on collision enter
2d when we go here for example for the
top spikes we set the box Collider to be
a trigger if you pay attention here you
see the is trigger checkbox is checked
as you can see now when we check that
checkbox for the trigger if we want to
detect collision between two game
objects we need to use on trigger enter
on trigger enter this is what we need is
if we checked the checkbox for is
trigger if we didn't check that checkbox
so it's not checked and we want to check
for collisions we will use on collision
enter so here I'm also going to name
collision to target and what I'm going
to test here is if our target game
object tag he is equal to player of
course your assignment here is to put
the player in a single script and then
call it from that script and also use
another way to compare game objects if
you don't know you're not sure search
online but this also works by the way so
here if target game object tag is the
player and if is breakable so that means
we landed on the breakable game object
or the breakable platform and the player
is the one who landed we are simply
going to call here our Sound Manager so
Sound Manager instance dot land
sound and below we are going to call our
atom that play to play the animation and
animation is a break we will be able to
see to hear this and I'm just gonna copy
this and below if is platform which
means we only land it on the platform we
are going to call this Sound Manager
instance to play the land music voila
this is what we need to do the before
lasting so we will also have in our
player bombs to detect collision but
here this is on collision
enter and this one is ontriggerenter so
on trigger enter okay this is when we
enter what we are going to do for the
moving platforms because I'm sugar enter
and I'll collision enter will not work
there well for them we need to use on
collision state and here we're going to
see void on collision stay to D you see
here called once per frame for every
Collider rigidbody duty that is touching
the rigidbody 2d Collider so it will
call and here I'm also going to change
the target so this is and here I'm going
to say in a class on collisions state
this is going to be called every single
frame as long as the player is standing
on the moving platforms and simply here
I'm going to test if target game object
tag is equal to the player which means
the player landed on the moving the
player landed on the moving platforms
I'm going to test if the moving platform
left then we're going to move the player
to the left and we're simply going to
see target game object get component and
we're going to get the player movement
and if you remember our platform
platform move and here I'm going to say
negative one half if you remember in our
player movement I created this platform
move I said we were going to use it for
the moving platforms the reason for that
is this one because now we are simply
going to call here platform move passing
the negative one and if we if we need to
move to the right side so right moving
platform right we're going to call plus
one of course you can create a separate
variable holding this movement variable
for the platform so that is up to your
actual that is your assignment not up to
you that is your assignment you're not
even asked here you need to do that or
otherwise I will I don't know what I
will do I cannot do anything okay I have
so much fun green in these tutorials we
can test this out but before we do that
I'm gonna go here in our player bounce
and below
and this one is for the check bounced Oh
check bounced
instead of me creating a separate
scripted text to test collision with the
top spikes I'm simply going to create
here on trigger enter 2d and this one is
going to be target and if so if target
tag is equal to top spike did I did I
tag it with the top spike or top spikes
we need to test that out we need to go
back here and see select the top spike
yeah top spike that is the name make
sure that the names match or otherwise
it will not work so if the target tag is
equal to the top spike what we're going
to do first of all we are going to say
transform position is equal to new
vector2 for our player and we're going
to set the player at 1000 1000 to move
him away from the screen then we're
going to call our sound manager instance
dot death death sound and our game
manager instance dot re start game voila
this is all we need to do and basically
we are done with this and we can test
this out so I can go back here in unity
and wait for unity to take mercy upon me
and for unity to well compile all the
scripts I can go here in console and
clear everything I'm going to try first
to land on the moving platform so that
we can see what's gonna happen so this
is a regular platform I'm hoping this
one is a regular one yeah a regular one
and this one is a red and yeah we are
gone we art that and by the way let me
go quickly here in our visual studio
what did we do for our player bounds yes
he here we are out of balance is true
and we need to call this to restart the
game so that's why nothing happened so
let's go here again and let's try it out
now so let's try to land ok here is the
moving plot no pay attention I'm not
doing anything and it's moving me slowly
to the right side you saw that you saw
that I mean you
blind use on that let's try to land on a
breakable platform so let's hope that
somewhere here we have a breakable part
on a regular platform regular one come
on we have a breakable and this is a
breakable you see Pam and it break it
broke you see and let's go here again
what happened for the breakable platform
well it happened that the animation was
blamed and when the animation hit the
last frame so if I go here select the
breakable and open it here we were
playing the animation so in the break we
play the animation Bam Bam Bam and when
it reached here it simply called the
animation event which called is
breakable deactivate function which is
here here is breakable deactivate which
invoked this one and it broke maybe we
can set it at 0.5 so it does not break
right away we can wait a moment or two
now before we continue or actually while
we're going to finish our game in two
sprints so let's go here and we see that
everything is working but we cannot test
things like when we touch our top spikes
I mean we can I can select the player
and you will see that he will be
position and 1000 1000 for the position
you see back he's gone his position is
1000 1000 but yeah that is that what we
need to do is and the player will fall
down soon you see and he fell down
because well because anyways we need to
restart the game when that happens first
of all let me go here in the scenes and
change this sample scene to gameplay
scene and go here in files and build
settings and we need to click this add
open seams which will add the current
scene to the build you see now we have
the scenes gameplay inside now we can
use now I can D act or actually load
that scene so let's go here in the
scripts and I'm going to right click
here and a folder and this was going to
be helper scripts and we're going to
have two helpers so first one is going
to be game manager and then other words
going to be sound man
and what I'm gonna do is reset their
positions to 0-0 starting with the G
manager so create a c-sharp script game
manager this one is going to be very
simple we're not gonna complicate things
we're simply going to restart the game
so go here attach it and right click
here and C sharp script Sound Manager
and attach the Sound Manager on the
Sound Manager game object so like this
first of all open the game manager and
as I said we're not gonna complicate
anything I'm going to say here class and
why why I need to restart my visual
studio I hate it when this happens man I
really do I really do and this happens
I'm assuming because I have probably in
my google chrome 30 tabs opened I did
not turn off my computer for I don't
know how long and my unity has been
running for some time as well so I'm
assuming that is the case or unity has a
bug
hey I'm not perfect so yeah so what are
we going to do in the game manager first
of all we're going to see public game
managers of public game manager instance
like this in the awake function we are
going to say if our instance is equal to
null we are going to say here instance
is equal to this and basically that is
that we only need two more functions one
is going to be public void restart game
which is going to invoke a function and
the function is going to be invoked is
void restart after time and simply here
we are going to say Unity engine that
scene management that scene manager dot
load scene and we are going to load the
game play scene simple as that so let's
go here I'm going to simply call it
actually no no we need to do this we
need to say here invoke and passing the
name which is the restart time and
you can say two seconds now this will
happen after we call our D manager and
we're going to call our D manager after
our player dies that is the only reason
when our D manager is going to be called
and when we are going to restart our
game we can test it out right now but I
would prefer that first we finish our
sound manager script which is this one
right here and with it we will be done
so let's go here and let me just go and
hit the class or tag the class and the
principal is gonna be the same we are
first going to create a public static
sound manager instance if you're not
familiar what an instance is I did not
said that here explain it I have a video
30 minute video explaining what is an
instance what our Singleton's I will put
the link in the description below if I
don't please remind me it can happen
that I will forget so here I'm going to
say awake and the reason why I will
forget is because I'm not going to
publish this tutorial to date I will
publish this tutorial probably 10 or 15
days after the recording that's why so
we're going to see here if instance is
equal to null meaning it does not have a
reference we are going to say instance
is equal to this pointing to this class
or this is the reference now below we
are going to have a private or actually
above excuse me we are going to have a
private audio source which is going to
be our sound FX and for the sound
effects we are going to have here
serialized fields private audio clips
and also our sound effects is also going
to be a serialized field so these clips
are going to be the land clip we are
also going to have the depth clip like
this we're also going to have the ice
break clip and the game over clip voila
simple as that now in order to play all
of these we need to create public
functions so here I'm going to say
public void the first one's going to be
land sound and simply what we're going
to do is we're going to call sound
effects that
clip is going to be equal to land clip
and sound effects that play simple as
that
nothing else now I can copy these lines
and we're going to create a public
public void and this one is going to be
ice break sound for the ice breaks out
we're simply going to say here ice break
clip and voila call that plate and we're
good to go then we're going to have a
public void death sound and you can
assume where this is going we're going
to see here that clip and voila and the
last thing is our public void game over
sound so game over sound like this paste
this here and here I'm going to say game
over clip in the play and voila we are
good to go before we test this out we do
need to go here in unity select the
sound manager and we are going to have
an audio source component this one is
gonna be for the background music so
we're going to make sure this play on
awake is turned on and loop is turned on
and for the clip I'm going to click here
so let's go here you see where if we
need to add an audio clip I'm going to
click on this little circle and filter
for the clips so I'm going to click on
the circle and we're going to filter for
the BG music here it is and I'm also
going to set the volume for the BG music
2.2 because I want these other sound
effects such as landing and game over
and that sound I want that to be heard
so that's why I'm putting the background
music to point to this is for the BG
music now here I'm going to have another
audio source and we're going to turn off
this play on awake and we're going to
drag and drop that audio source here in
the sound effects so drag and drop the
second not the first one not this one
holding the BG music not the folded one
this one that's not folded drag and drop
it here and yes we can drag and drop
components in scripts that can work as
well because we have two audio sources
attached on this game
object if we use getcomponent here we
don't know which one will be returned so
we can return the BG sound and then we
will stop playing the BG music and here
let's filter for these land that ice
breaking game over clip so here I'm
going to filter for the land here it is
this one is the death clip so let's find
it here that this one is the ice break
here it is and the last one is the game
over so click on this one game over here
it is game over so make sure that you
attach all of these to the appropriate
slots again you see here sounds you also
have a readme file make sure that you
read it for the sounds so here you see
BG music we have the death over so on it
so we have the star as well but I'm not
going to do that that's your assignment
and with this we are done programming
everything what we need to do is simply
go here play your bounds we need to turn
this off you see or actually uncomment
this so instance what did I gain manager
instance public static game manager
instance this is what we need to do so
public static game manager instance so
now I can call it here see simply out
comment everywhere where we comment
these lines of code uncommon them also
here for our platformer scripts
uncommented here and here I don't think
we don't have anywhere else and here and
here and voila and also I think for the
player bounce yeah we did that yeah
everything is OK literally we're done
this is our game so let's try it out so
if I go here we will now here the player
sounds every time we hit a spike or fall
out of Bounce we will restart the game
so let's hit that play button and see
that in action you hear the sound and do
you hear when we fall on a platform yes
you do for the spike or actually for the
moving platform I remove the falldown
sound so
let's go again and game over and now
we're going to restart you see and by
the way I think this is too much for the
breakable platform where it is where is
it platform script where is the plate
breakable I think this is too much
maybe 35 or I don't know point 35 this
is okay this is okay so let's go back
and again I'm going to turn it off turn
it off run the game so make sure that we
listen to these sound effects when we
fall on a platform with the platform
brakes and also when we go out of bounce
and when we restart the game maybe I
should go in the sound manager and for
the audio source for the BG music set it
at point 1 so that we can hear it even
louder or actually don't hear the BG
music louder but hear the effects louder
this is what I meant so let's go here
and hit the play button so you heard
that sub beta G you hear that and let's
try to die and bam we did we did we did
okay so let's go here again and on the
moving platforms I did not put that and
you see it's moving us and bam we died
and the game is restarting again over
and over again until we quit playing it
so let's go here and let's try to land
here and back we found out you see you
see again we are restarting the game so
it's an endless game let's try to go
here and we cannot so our
congratulations to getting till the end
I still have a star if we go here in the
sprites you will see an assets in
sprites you see that we have a star and
what you can do is and this is your
assignment you can add the star make it
a collectible item and pick it up in the
game and you can also make a score out
of the star so this is your assignment
for the game so that you can practice I
have plenty tutorials showing you how
that collectible item so on and so forth
so this one is up to you congratulations
do you get until the end Isis are small
hyper casual games games it's a plural
nah it's actually a singular not a
plural it's a small hyper casual game
congratulations to
finishing this game even though it looks
small we had a lot of things to think
about how can we spawn these platforms
how create code this so on and so forth
anyways download this tutorial link is
in the description below the project the
complete project and finished project
and the tutorial sets link is in the
description below and fire here again
thank you for watching I will see you
guys in another video